So the core hypotheses that I'm
developing in my research are that an
inclusive national narrative, one that's
based on creeds,
ideas, principles—some of you've
read Fukuyama's recent work on
identity, he calls this "credo-nationalism"—that that, all else being equal, helps
actually to support democracy. Whereas an
exclusive national narrative—one that's
based on fixed identities of race,
religion, caste, ethnicity, religion being
fixed in most parts of the world as an
identity—undermines democracy, all else
being equal. And before I kind of
unpack those hypotheses and what I'm
doing to research and test
these, I want to I wanted to spend a
moment on two questions I often get
asked when I present this research. So
the first question is: am I not really
collapsing the distinction between
patriotism and nationalism, right? So
isn't patriotism all the good
stuff about feeling love for one's
country and nationalism all the bad
stuff? Well, no serious scholar that I
know of nationalism actually takes that
distinction very seriously. It's a very
big part of the public debate, but the
very same actions can look, can be
described as patriotic or nationalist
depending on whether you like them or
not, and what outcomes you think that
they have. But to describe a phenomenon analytically, it's important not to
describe it based on its consequences,
but to be able to describe the
phenomenon in and of itself. And love for
one's country certainly can just be part
of, because...So patriotism can, some
research has shown, quite easily slide
into nationalism,
especially when circumstances of threat
arise. The second question I get asked a
lot is: isn't the ideal world one
in which we don't have national
identities at all?
Why celebrate national identities? Why really promote them in some sense if
the ideal world is one in which we all
just...our primary identities are ones
that are based on our common humanity.
And the answer I give to that is that
there's a lot of social psychology
research that shows that human beings
are by their very nature clannish; they
need communities. And that in fact the
countries around the world that we've
seen that don't have a national identity,
that've come closest to not having a
national identity, are not utopian but in
fact very dystopian. And what you see
here is a picture of Somalia, where there
is no clear national identity at all.
So I go about this research, as I said
I'm at the very beginning of this
project, so this is a sort of a,
relatively light on a lot of evidence.
But I'm I'm going to tell you about how
I'm going about this research in
three domains. The first domain is that
I'm looking at, to look at like
for like. I'm looking at all countries
that gained colonial independence in the
1940s and 50s and 60s and looking at
their founding constitutions and
creating an index of inclusivity based
on such questions as: does the preamble of
the Constitution, the part that begins
with "We the People," is there a definition
of the nation that mentions race,
religion or region. Is there a religious
or racial category that's required for
to either be at the head of state or to
serve in an important distinction of
government. And using these kinds of
questions I create an inclusivity
index that I'm statistically looking at
whether it has that, has a pattern with a
whole bunch of databases that look at
democracy. So I'm in the process right
now of putting that together. So that's
the first way I do that.
The second way that I do that
(investigate the relationship between
nationalism and democracy) is that I'm
looking at some experiments which show
that when you look at, you ask
individuals how much are you willing to
give to co-ethnics or
co-religionists in need. And that when
you actually prime individuals, for
example, by showing them a national flag
they're actually,
everyone is more likely to give to their
co-ethnics in most contexts. But when you
prime individuals by showing the
national flag, they actually are less
likely to want to give to -
they're equally likely to want to give
to members of their nation. So it very
much shows that nationalism is a force
for solidarity. And the third way, and
that's the one I'm going to talk about
a little bit more tonight, is that I'm
looking at countries that are largely
similar, so three sets of countries that
are largely similar on those
explanations I gave you, but that have
very different national identities at
their founding. And I trace over time
whether and how those national
identities get used in moments of crisis.